there's all sorts of crazy stuff going
on none of which has to do with the fact
that 3,000 of my countrymen are dying
when I got to know you and I think when
millions of other people got to know you
was on September 11th 2001 you were
anchoring CNN's morning coverage that
morning but she probably thought was
just going to be like any other morning
and then very quickly it was not there
was a rumor out there that you've
already started correcting me before we
started here but that was actually your
first day at CNN but you're telling me
that's not the case no it's such a good
story you know you know I don't know how
many times I've been interviewed I don't
know how many times this has come up I
don't know how many times I said
honestly I love this story too I wish it
was true but it's not and it's such a
good story that they would write it
anyway it shows how did that come to be
that people thought that that was
reverse morning sorry how did that come
to be that people thought that that was
your first morning on CNN well I'm not
sure I know if I were to guess you know
there are days and there are days and I
had been doing I mean I heard that
weekend show I did 20 night lines a year
I was on television a fair amount in my
life but none of those days is 9/11 and
so all of a sudden this kind of
funny-looking dude with glasses shows up
on your TV screen on the biggest day in
your country's modern history and you
say well that's not Peter and that's not
Dan and that's Tom and I've never seen
this funny like I do before he must be
new and
I honestly think that's what happened
that it wasn't that it you know on an
average nine CNN and you'll probably had
a million people watching the president
stem-cell speech President Bush's
stem-cell speech which I incurred was in
August maybe a million people watch that
twenty million people in America watch
not eleven one and a quarter billion
people around the world watch CNN and
four from September eleventh to
Thanksgiving I was on TV I mean I you
you couldn't avoid me I was like a
disease and I was constantly there I was
on TV eight hours a day every day until
we finally finally went home to my wife
and kid and with one away for
Thanksgiving weekend so I just think the
newness of it all probably helped create
the myth but you know what that's the
worst myth there is about you I can live
with that yeah that's pretty good
alright well hopefully we've dispelled
that fake news for all the time but but
let's talk about that morning so
obviously you had had plenty of other
jobs in broadcasting well before that in
anchoring and all sorts of things but
clearly there was nothing that could
possibly prepare you for what was going
to happen that morning as 8:47 rolled
around what what was it like that
morning well it was crazy I don't know
that I understand what you mean when you
say nothing can prepare you for that
because that's actually in a kind of
literal way true nothing you've never
dealt with the attack on your country
all of these things at 9/11 was all of
that's true on the other hand
I thought I think I prepared my whole
life for that day I had no one wants
that day but if there's going to be a
day like that I wanted to be the person
to tell the story
I felt capable of telling the story I
understood the magnitude of the story I
had done the 93 World Trade Center
bombing by Al Qaeda
I felt like knew what was happening at
the same time I'm not gonna lie to you I
mean there's a there's that little part
of every guy who's going do not screw
this up and do not make this worse this
is a horrible day in your country's
history and the last thing we need is
for you to do something stupid um so
that was there yeah so the main thing
and the reason why I wanted to have you
on and I've actually been trying to
track you down for for quite some time
is that as someone that lived in New
York City during 9/11 I mean all of us
you know we would go out for groceries
but basically beyond that we were we
were glued to the television and not
just people that lived in New York City
everybody that lived in America and
really across the world but there was
something about your demeanor
there was a calmness and a decency to it
that is so I would say the complete 180
of so much of what cable news has become
now and I'm wondering is that just
something that is sort of personally
part of who you are is that sort of what
you wanted your television persona to be
or did it all just sort of unfurl as
live thank you I mean I take that all as
a compliment I don't know that I ever
there was a period when I was at ABC
when I thought I had a television
persona and it was horrible I mean I was
honestly I you know it was it was I
thought I was supposed to be Peter
I admired Peter I thought I was supposed
to be more formal than I am I'm just a
guy from a small town in Minnesota yeah
I think I'm at my best
or was it
my best when I was just me and I am
actually fairly called I go on I'm not
much of a hyper you know I don't like I
don't want to use any one's as an
example but um I don't use the word
dramatic very often I don't tell people
this is gonna be dramatic it's if it's
dramatic to them as dramatic to them why
don't you remember do you remember
feeling the pressure though as that
first plane hit and it was still unclear
whether it was a terrorist attack do you
remember flailing be in heaven pressure
I mean the first plane yet I wasn't on
TV so I don't know on the second plane
when a stand plane yet I knew what was
happened
yeah first plane I thought I don't know
maybe maybe somebody had a heart attack
I don't mean I'd come into LaGuardia
hundreds of times and you come up that
you would come up the river and you'd go
past the Trade Center and I thought well
I don't know I mean crazy stuff happened
somebody crashed into the building when
the second plane here then there was no
question anymore right I I said this is
a attack on the country this is al Qaeda
you know what else has to wherewithal to
pull off something like this this is a
this is the there wasn't a war on terror
as such but this is the war on terror
beginning this is it
yeah what's it like being in a newsroom
in in those moments when something truly
horrific is happening hmm someone who
was in the newsroom well they're fine
they're funneling information to you and
here I I know that for example I mean I
was on the roof of a building
thirty-eight eighth and they do it
wasn't a studio they were trying to
throw up lights and just crazy stuff was
going on I'm afraid of heights
and guys are on scaffolding so I'm
afraid someone's gonna fall off and it
was nuts in the control room I was
pretty sure was crazy cuz I've been in
control rooms but the controller's job
in case you don't know you probably do
know this is the game I don't know it
yeah right however crazy they are at any
given moment they do not transmit that
insanity to you because what you need to
know is information and that everything
is under control it's not yeah and
there's some part of you that knows it's
not the things that we're supposed to
work aren't working that was someone who
was supposed to be ready
isn't that somebody says something
stupid you're gonna have to correct all
those things are going on there yelling
at each other remember I was doing the
weekend show it ABC and I brought my
daughter and she was probably seven or
eight years old maybe a little older and
she was in the control room and after
the show she came down and she she was a
78 year old hood why should she be shown
not that she cared that her dad was
doing the TV show it was just the magic
and she said dad you know they say the
f-word up there yeah I think there are
two different places this is the place I
occupied which I owned I own that space
the the people there were reflective of
my emotional state and supported my
emotional state which was calm and
there's that other world the newsroom
which is crazy to control room which is
insane everybody who's making there's
Atlanta which is wanting control of the
show there's all sorts of crazy stuff
going on
none of which has to do with the fact
that 3,000 of my countrymen are dying
[Music]